[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna get to Howie Mandel in one
second hi everyone
I just wanted to give some context for
the Howie Mandel interview it was one of
my favorites uh we've done because he is
so brilliant he is so eloquent and also
just so ridiculously funny and it just
goes back and forth from Super
interesting and insightful and poignant
to like super funny and ridiculous at um
you know I think that we addressed this
in the interview but I think that you
know growing up with little monsters and
and you know movies he was in and
knowing him as a comedian and then you
know I I relate to this the idea of
being like you know a sort of a really
funny comic and then you end up doing
you know network television he was on
you know Deal or No Deal he hosted that
forever
um starring uh none other than uh Meghan
Markle with a briefcase and uh then he
is now the host of uh America's Got
Talent you know so I think people kind
of you have to have your hands tied
behind your back when you do stuff like
that I don't know why I'm stuttering so
much I had a long weekend at gang Fest I
don't know it's lockjaw I swear I didn't
suck any dicks but my jaw is just like
not interested in Mobility at the moment
um so in the beginning we really like
break down comedy what's going on with
comedy right now why it's so dangerous
you know what mistakes we're making
what's going on with the comedy and you
know a lot of people are sort of
obsessed with this you know comedy's
dead and you can't say anything anymore
really break down why that's happening
and the ramifications of it and then
also uh we get super ridiculous and
funny towards the end um I kind of want
to invert the interviews to start with
super funny but I'm just not going to be
insecure about this because Howie is the
greatest he's a legend his mind is
incredible I'm just blown away by him
it's so rare that you meet one of your
Heroes and they're not like trying to
give you a way too long hug so well
Howie I mean maybe he wanted to but he's
germaphobics and I look filthy
the hair extensions do look they look a
little bit ratchet but you know what
here's the thing hot take Russian
bitches I know that Russia is a bad you
know dictator fascist state but they're
eating healthy like something's going
right over there because this is their
hair you know what I mean like they're
eating well I think I think of Vladimir
Putin as someone like starves everyone
and like whatever but I don't know
whatever they're eating is definitely
like getting that her thick so I love
you guys I am on tour soon I'm just
doing clubs to work on new stuff uh I am
getting on only fan soon because I'm
gonna put all of uh the jokes that I
can't say here because it'll get
demonetized or out of the algorithm or
flagged or whatever I'm gonna start
putting them on only fans so instead of
dirty photos and dirty videos it's gonna
be dirty jokes that I can't tell
anywhere else so that's going to start
soon and um I'm sorry this interview is
a little bit long I just was so
fascinated by Howie and he was so funny
I'm gonna start making them shorter I
promise I guess I'm gonna have to start
getting less interesting and hilarious
guests
mental
[Music]
[Laughter]
ity is a rough week my psychiatrist told
me I'm going crazy I said if you don't
mind like a second opinion he's all
right your ugly toes he's just so good
wow I think we've lost the definition of
Comedy you know comedy is
supposed to be the reason it's funny is
because it's wrong you know and and we
use this term now too soon like you
could talk about something that's got a
little bit of an you know by the way
anyone that says a joke is too soon is
usually a man that comes too soon
no and then I've never said too soon
it's like you fuck who do you
that's why we're saying it because it's
too soon right or because it's wrong or
because you know you can call your wife
crazy you can call your wife ugly
because you're not supposed to otherwise
it's comedy there's no I don't know if
we talked about that on on my on my
podcast but I said that you know people
always go that's wrong or you can't say
that the truth the matter is comedy
comes from Darkness comedy comes from
things that are wrong things that we are
taught not to do as a little child if
you're laughing at a clown in the circus
you don't laugh unless that clown falls
down or something happens they go out to
get like mauled by uh Rodeo uh what are
the things that buck you off bulls yeah
it's clowns the rodeo clown but the
rodeo Clown's got to be in trouble so
you're all you're definitely laughing at
somebody else's Misfortune which by for
all intents and purposes is wrong right
you're taught that's not the way Society
should act if somebody's in trouble if
somebody falls down you shouldn't laugh
at it yet that's the exact rule of
Comedy if somebody falls down they're
falling down so you will laugh at it as
comedians we are also and and this
happens all the time I don't know if you
do or you're asked to do corporate dates
but at corporate dates they'll as
comedians we get no respect that this is
great with him on on board but they'll
say you can't do the dick joke you can't
do but you know what that's why I pay so
well too you know I think on some level
you would never hire the Rolling Stones
and saying you can't do the song
Satisfaction right you can't do the fact
that they're taking they hired you
because you're funny for what you do but
they feel that is their right to say hey
we want you
but don't say this don't say that but
they will they will hire you because of
all the hits that you have and the way
you are Whitney Cummings is an edgy but
if you've already seen those jokes I
can't tell them because then there's no
surprise so anything that you've seen
that you liked the reason you liked it
because it was shocking and surprising I
can't tell the same thing again that I'm
a hack you know so it's like it is like
people you know I think that I like that
people don't understand us I like I I
there's something I don't here's the
here's the thing though hasn't this
always happened uh I'm obsessed with the
idea that everything that exists today
has always existed it just looked
differently I mean we talk about Lenny
Bruce and we think about I mean they
tried to cancel The Simpsons they try to
cancel Eminem remember there was like
there's always an outrage but we you
know as we started with Rodney Rodney
started with I get no respect no comic
gets respect I'm on America's Got Talent
you know and if you come on and you sing
a song that is top 40 you know that you
didn't write yeah and you stand in a
spot and you sing the song and I think a
lot of people I'm not knocking singing I
can't sing but a lot of people can you
can walk into a Ramada Inn and hear
somebody you can be on a cruise and hear
somebody fantastic you could be sitting
around the campfire and your friend
could be sitting there strumming on a
guitar and sing like you've never heard
before a lot of people can do it and
then you take a song that you've heard
and you learned and I'm not knocking the
fact that they get a standing ovation
and they get the votes the next person
that comes out is a comic who creates a
character writes every word delivers
everything and needs to elicit more from
an audience than any other form of
entertainment you know if you sing a
song they get to play their whole song
and then at the end because you don't
hear it anymore we know we're supposed
to applaud or go guess what I I actually
you know there is an obsession I think
with Comics musicians are kind of
obsessed with us you know like I'll go
out to an event or work thing and like a
famous musician like I could never do
what you do and I'm like yeah like
that's true you know because we hear
every single thing you guys drown it out
if someone doesn't like you you have no
idea and you are protected by
instruments you have all this other
stuff like right what we do is terror is
terrifying well I talk about the fact
that and I'm not knocking music I love
music I cannot I don't have that Talent
yeah but somebody writes a song the fact
that they write a song and they go I'm
not this is not a song but these are
parts of a song you know I went into the
bar la la la la they can write la la la
you're saying this because I was
literally like working kind of on a bit
about this which is rappers so was I
rappers I really respect because they
got to fill in words Lil Wayne Eminem
some of these brilliant gangsters Move
Like Pat I got it wrong once on the show
the wrong way is funny well gangsters
move
Real G's real G's moving silence like
lasagna
okay that's fucking brilliant you know
it's like because I was like oh lasagna
I guess is really quiet no the g is
silent in lasagna you know it's like
Real G's moving sounds like I mean
that's like nine levels of puns and
double entenders and so you know but
really just spelling please
you're making it much more than it is
but I get it well I'm about to really
slam musicians so I'm trying to just pan
by a little bit you know I have a Howie
is spelled with a six and that's also
silent
it's h-o-w-6-i-e
so I'm like lasagna
hi did you get the food Howie is killing
you would like our relationship is so
like he's like this is the funniest
whatever so I just said Hi how are you I
love you as I comes on sharing besides
on the road with me all the time uh he's
just the greatest and I just said like I
respect rappers I don't respect
musicians because please what's your
name
yeah yeah not to be confused with the
guy that just got released after 32
years no that was me yeah
you know what I'm talking about he just
got released from the president from the
from the podcast where they thought what
was his name oh you know what I'm
talking about that was Zayed oh Zayed
who's that there's that podcast it was
the most famous pod it was the most
serial serial podcast he got released do
you not know that he got he got uh
charged with killing his girlfriend
uh-huh and and remember that was the
first crime podcast I remember it was
called sure sure and we we talked to
Syed we could hear him talking from his
cell at least on why because uh they
they uh there's too many living women in
America
that's why yeah you guys believe it
abortionate terms so I just said like I
respect some rappers the way I respect
comedians as writers like because of the
silent G well no
G's move in silence like lasagna get it
do not put you you get it don't put your
hand in Howie's coverage it's okay it's
all right no it's not no he probably
thought I was gonna cough
there's a hand went in front of the
camera I like it they always cover my
mouth
whether I'm talking and then because I'm
working on it teaches music also you
teach music I argue that writing a song
is not that hard no no no writing music
no writing music I think is Hard music
is Hard lyrics Words lyrics that's not
so hard I think the fact that you say I
wrote a song and it's you know
you can write la la la is considered a
lyric right so what I'm saying is that
when someone's like well this musician
like people that like walk on eggshells
around these the women they're like
divas I'm like you literally go la la la
like I don't can you imagine writing
comedy like that two guys walk into a
bar and then
wow you are a songwriter I didn't
realize
why are we like oh my God this person
needs nine assistants and this person
don't look him in the eye like
but there was but we were talking about
the respect of uh music or acting over
stand-up comedy which exists you know it
I I think I was at uh one time an award
was being given to Jerry Seinfeld and I
think was it the Aspen Comedy Festival
now you're blocking my shot oh yeah
that's sorry about that yeah you know
what take the hat off and it just looks
like that'll be a great like I'm over
you're a stand-up comedian you know you
have to talk into this you've not but he
has nothing to say right now no he was
going to say something about that
silence is golden what if I just went to
sleep that's so long without getting you
cucumbers anyway the point that I'm
making is that uh Seinfeld I'm I'm going
to paraphrase said he's not used to
receiving an award as a comedian because
in this and we as comedians create a
character write the script hit the yeah
write it down because you're so equipped
I'm writing my suicide note sorry
continue
no I'm writing down something that's
gonna that Geraldo said once that I want
to say after yeah Geraldo said something
Geraldo Greg Geraldo Oh I thought I
thought I thought it was going to be and
then we cut to him going there's nothing
there's nothing in this in this Vault
there is nothing in this Vault oh I just
got hit with a chair I just got hit with
a chair I didn't know who you were
talking or what's the other anyway Greg
Giraldo but anyway he said that I'm not
used to getting an award because I'm a
comedian you know and a comedian is put
on at the end of the show The Comedian
is like the cleanup clown the comedian
though writes every word creates a
character and has to deliver it and
needs to elicit more from an audience
than any other form of uh any other form
of entertainment an actor doesn't drive
to work usually gets picked up and then
somebody they sit in a chair where
somebody Combs their hair puts on their
makeup dresses them then they're taken
they're led to another room and they're
told to stand over there where that
piece of tape is and they're told to say
this they're paid 10 million dollars
while everyone around not even the money
but everyone around them is making a
hundred that's another issue but the
issue that I'm making is they go read
this line and then you go cut not like
that read it again no not like that cut
no no and then they shoot it again from
another angle and then another angle and
then they go back they take them back to
their trailer they wait and they shoot
the whole thing and it doesn't matter
really what they did post it's fixed and
then they fix it the best cuts of each
and then we watch music under it no and
then we go to the Academy Awards and we
go he's brilliant who does he vote for
tell us about politics we will do
anything you do you are the best
Pretender in the world where the comic
is just the cleanup and you guys are the
professional liars and where are the
professional truth tellers so there is
one's getting in trouble and at AGT
where people show up and sing a song and
do things get so much more adulation
than the comic I always support the
comic I go you don't know it but it's
easy to say or to hear these words you
don't know how hard this is even if you
didn't get the joke it's very hard to
kind of appease everyone in the room may
I just quote Brody Stevens real quick
no if you
if you don't get me you're dumb
that's what Brody would say because
Brody was like so nine levels of satire
and he just would say like you're dumb
if you don't get he would open with that
and it just killed me it is amazing but
it is also you realize how specific
comedy is in the sense that when I go to
an amateur night or a an open mic night
the comics get on and you go you see
people die and it's ridiculous and it's
horribly bad and you go why is this
person even think they can be a comedian
and they're there nobody's there I don't
think of their own volition I think
they're there because Uncle Nathan at uh
at Thanksgiving went you so funny you
should be comedian or one friend you
said you're saying Nathan had a lot of
drinks out night right but they made
Nathan laugh and now in front of a room
everybody's sitting there going what the
fuck is this right but but the point is
that you know everything I was ever
expelled for hit for gotten in trouble
for is what I get paid for you know I
got up on a dare and I'm just lucky that
the whole room laughed and I didn't know
what to do when I first got up on stage
it was like I didn't have I didn't plan
you do a lot more work than me I don't
do work I kind of go I fly by the seat
of my pants and I was going okay okay
okay like if you look at my old I
couldn't think of anything and because I
have OCD I have I had rubber gloves
because I would out in public I didn't
want to touch anything in public
restrooms and I put my hands in my
pocket and I had a rubber glove and I I
didn't know what to do and I pulled it
over my head and I inflated it and it
popped off and that and the crowd
applauded that fucking rubber glove
bought me two homes so what I'm saying
is I'm just lucky that whatever I did
happened to click with a larger audience
than just Uncle Nathan and when I popped
and I sold I think I talked to you about
this when I sold uh two shows out at uh
in one night in a couple of minutes at
Radio City Music Hall I remember in
between shows being in the dressing room
looking out onto Seventh Avenue or
whatever it is with my wife and there's
you know 7 000 people teaming out at one
show seven thousand people coming in 14
000 people in the street cops stanchions
everything but my wife says what are you
thinking and I'm thinking in this town
of 10 million people you know uh nine
million 983
000 people don't give a fuck and don't
want to put up any money so there's
always more that don't get it and don't
care and that's what we were talking
about before we're going hey you don't
get it you don't care let me read your
thoughts and take them seriously you
know now it used to be if someone you
know you know didn't fuck with you or
had negative things to say you know I
know that when we leave theaters and
there's a bunch of people out front I
like I just because chances are there
could be a couple of people going yeah
that one joke I don't know about this
like it's not my business like I
shouldn't hear that you know I shouldn't
here the water cooler conversation now
with Twitter we have the opportunity to
hear the water cooler conversation half
of it is it an opportunity what do you
mean you think of it as an opportunity
we have the um ability ability Gregory
great
um and uh to to hear all the stuff that
we shouldn't hear it's just really none
of our business and also it's like to me
like I know that when I see a movie I
like go out of my way to just be like
Devil's Advocate like that was not good
and then people hated it I'm like it was
good you guys like I'm just that you
know so I don't even know if half the
stuff that's reading is just people
trying to be interesting and trying to
have an opinion because that's what
humans do you know but it's really
well humans don't want to say they being
nice is not fun I mean that's what I and
and being nice is is work yeah you know
just having a pleasant face is work
having a smile is work but you know what
boils to the top is what you didn't like
and what you didn't you know if you read
a review a review you know the people
that became the biggest reviewers of the
time are the people that could give
scathing reviews I think those are the
things you're going to read can I say
something it's I believe it's a podcast
you should be seeing a lot of things I
feel like no trust me the more I talk in
these the the worse it gets for me but
um so uh uh I think it's an Oscar Wilde
quote I know a lot of things where I'm
sure something you know who knows like
everything's attributed in Maryland
Oscar Wilde who fucking knows like but
he said critics are people that go to
the battle site where the war was fought
and they shoot the survivors
wow like it's just to me that's a Critic
like try to do what we here's my thing
about critics try to do what we do you
don't have to be good at it but just so
you know the level of difficulty that's
all you cannot review well I think it's
about respect you know people don't we
we've lost that in society and aside
from Comedy and everything it's just
respect it respect the fact that that's
another human being yeah when Comics are
like performing and critics are like
well this person's trash like yeah we
agree but that's why we do you know what
I mean but I don't think you know people
talk and maybe this is uh maybe this is
sacrilegious what I'm about to say but
people talk about Carson being you know
I did The Tonight Show with Carson 22
times I felt that that was the ultimate
place of some disrespect and I'll tell
you why because everybody wanted to get
on the Johnny Carson show because the
public made that you know before I did
Johnny I did
um uh Merv Griffin Mike Douglas Joan
River you know not John Rivers Joan
Rivers was after Joan Rivers brought me
to The Tonight Show but but the but the
truth of the matter was you know
somebody who didn't know me would say
what do you do and I'd say I'm a
comedian and they go have you ever been
on Johnny Carson that was their first
question that that meant something and
if you talk to comics of my era that was
the litmus test for being considered
legitimate for women it was did you ever
blow with Johnny Carson
that's still being on Johnny
but the point that I'm making is the
comic regardless of who you were always
went on last yeah on the show and people
talk with such Pride the first time I
was on Johnny gave me the thumbs up
Johnny called me to the couch so you
weren't even allowed he called me to the
couches in his office back to the
blowing but the point that I'm making is
the the point that I'm making is he
called like if he felt that you did good
enough then you were allowed to sit down
and talk where if you were and I'm not
knocking him in any way but if you were
Donny Most who was on Happy Days who was
not Henry Winkler and not the the star
of the show third tier level on the on a
sitcom that was a hit he would be the
first or second guest and they'd sit
down and talk to him he didn't write any
of the lines that he said they talked to
him and then next you'd have a comedian
who sat and wrote every one of those
lines killed the audience and you felt
great if you got a thumbs up or if he
said come sit down you sat down you
talked to him for 30 seconds and they
went to Commercial and that was the end
of the show so is that really respect so
by the same token that kind of
disrespect
is very evident today where because
you're a comedian they think you have
this incredible funny thick skin where
on the other hand they're like you guys
are all come from trauma right you're
all mentally ill right and depressed and
then the next day they think we have
thick skin it's like which is it you
know like well because you should know
better because your whole thing is like
all comedians are traumatized right but
you you know how to take that trauma and
make a joke and make it light so even
pity us and then they bully us that's a
weird like pick a lane but your thing is
words and the thing that's different
today is you know the fact that it was
even if you weren't a comedian something
is packaged in the way of a joke that
used to be the safety net and that
doesn't happen anymore so if you said
something that was offensive to somebody
and they turned around what the fuck
with the and you could say in regular
just joking I was just joking and they
go oh I'm sorry I thought you were but
Comics this is my biggest thing with
like dating guys and stuff they'll say
something shitty they're like I'm just
joking I'm like no you're not you know a
lot of people use that as a defense when
but it doesn't work anymore when yeah
when the insult doesn't go over well
they're like I'm joking and you're like
I think I would know the difference but
but what we're talking about is even in
a club or even on your on on television
if you're joking about something that
somebody finds offensive there's a good
chance you can lose a big portion of
your career
Eve and you're joking you don't even
have to say I'm joking it's my comedy
special it's a joke so there's a
dichotomy between you know trying to
appease everybody and then trying to
make everybody use we were talking about
this before we got on making everybody
laugh and all of us as comedians you
know you can be in a room of 10 000
people who are just and and you're just
creating waves and waves of hilarity and
laughter and it's deafening and you
could look out and there's one face one
face
not laughing and then your whole focus
goes to I don't care about that that has
happened to me I think I've told this
story Ad nauseam I remember one night
just and and the thing about comedy is
you can get into a rhythm where once you
get that audience and once they're on
that roll it's even the things that
you're saying that are mediocre they're
caught in the in it's hypnotic you're
just in a flow State people are laughing
and if you looked and you had those
shots there's tears coming out of
people's eyes and they're they're
rocking in their seats and they're just
you just have that laughter it's just
that flow you're the tide of laughter is
huge and you look down at one person
who isn't laughing and you your whole
the rest of the room becomes quiet in
your mind and you focus on that one
person I remember I was at a doing a big
concert and that was happening and there
was a guy in the front row and he was um
not only not laughing but uh not even
looking in my direction you know he's
just sitting there like often like like
also my favorite is when I go that
motherfucker didn't laugh like that
person has cerebral palsy uh well that's
what I was gonna say that's exactly no
that you didn't ruin it but I love that
everyone it takes it down they're like
oh he's German he doesn't speak English
that's it and you're just like you
asshole right but I do so that's what
happened so I went what the fuck he's
not even looking at me and the lady
behind beside him goes he's blind
and I like an idiot just repeated
because I don't know that the seven
thousand people right
right I go he's blind and you could hear
the air you know just oh their their
hearts just dropped into their stomach
and I went oh lee fuck and then out of
nowhere it just came because I like that
stream of Consciousness I said I figured
the whole evening was just lost and I
just sucked the air out of the the funny
balloon of the night and I just said
wait a minute wait a minute he's blind
why the fuck would you pay for front row
seats for a blind man when you could put
them way up in the balcony where you
could tell him you can lie to him and
tell him he's got front row seats number
one it wouldn't fuck up my show and that
he's blind and you're dumb sorry
but those kind of things happen all the
time to us you know you go what's wrong
with him yes you show up or you show up
to a show and you're like oh this is my
last show before I shoot my special I'm
really good and then it's if you are uh
deaf the venue has to provide a sign
language person by law right so and
there's a one show there's someone right
next to you on stage going thing
like and you're just like I this is all
I love that joke but it's like there's
all I always love finding out what the
sign language uh term is for you know
it's like blow job and then I want she's
like I know anal taint fingering and
then you see sometimes they try to
figure it out you say taint in sign
what's that no what's that do you know
what the tank is no you don't know what
a tank is what is taint in sign language
do I know what it is in sign language no
do you know why did you do this uh
no I know what it is it's between the
asshole and the period
right it's true the asshole on the
period you said you said something about
periods right wait taint ASL
ASL yes that's big what what it's a big
taint wait no it's just long read it
read it it's sign language hold on this
is oh there's there's many ASL
dictionary taint it's a lot it's very
long and drawn out oh here he is angry
mad why do you have it he's angry man at
the table right I mean tanks make me
very angry and very mad but we're gonna
see the darn hold on you're showing me
everything but you're taint here we go
it's this one they used a woman this is
tan
what that's not tame that's changed are
you implying that everything on the
internet isn't true that she said a lot
more than taint sometimes it's I don't
know I don't think that was where were
we when I asked um uh what like it was I
was Benton and he asked but it was like
what's like the offensive word to use
for gay man in uh uh sign language like
what's queer like what's pejorative for
gay man and I think it was oh it was
this
like it's like fixing eyebrows like what
it was like don't do that the people
watch it yeah no well sorry you're going
away you don't touch your eyebrows on a
public I'm not playing anything anymore
I don't give a shit but um can I say two
things number one
um I remember being at the roast because
I started doing the roast I know they're
not for everyone
um you know I'm gonna start doing them
for only fans it's kind of called like
only comedy fans because I do think of
mistakes I'm the only fan site yes but
it's gonna be the first project for only
fans TV so it'll be free and then I'm
doing these separate roasts on are you
fancy dressed yes I'm dressed well I
think of only fans as not actually
Instagram and Twitter are way more you
go on only fans it's very wholesome it's
like kind of teachers only fans is
wholesome okay
here's what I'll say it's a lot of like
teachers that are making 30 grand a year
to risk maybe going into school and
getting shot in the face while just
trying to teach toddlers they're getting
paid 30 and then they go and they're
just like have bikinis on they're and
they're making 200 Grand like good for
them I think that's so you think you the
only fans no I'm not looking for Twitter
and Instagram Instagram is like like
it's terrible only fans just call
wholesome is our education system it's
our teacher it's paying the women that
deserve more yeah that's exactly what's
not only women but it's everybody sure
yeah but it's good wholesome
entertainment and you'll be there now
and it's safe sex work I think that's
awesome so my thing is instead of dirty
videos and dirty photos it's dirty jokes
all the jokes we can't tell you about
why wouldn't you do it on like patreon
or patreon uh uh because
um I think that's a little bit of lead
us at the moment I'm the latest and you
want to do work for the teachers I just
want to support teachers who either way
I didn't get shot in the face whether
they're on only fair
the money shot come on so uh so my my
issue right now is that I know it's hard
to be a comedian right cool but we our
daughter's a teacher I wonder if she's
not only my daughter oh the one I met um
to a teacher well if her primary job is
your travel Booker she doesn't need some
extra cash
but I don't I'm not on only fans I just
want to find out if she's supplementing
so I think we are putting ourselves like
comedians in situations we shouldn't be
putting ourselves in so we're leaving
the delivery up to people that don't do
comedy so we write a joke we put it on
Twitter for free and then I don't write
jokes on Twitter totally but most of the
people that are getting in trouble with
this kind of stuff are comedians that
are delivering part of Comedy is just
isn't only what you're saying is if
you're going to get canceled you want to
be paid for it
there's not even that it's I think what
we're doing is we are leaving up the
delay I'm not you're you're making me
nervous right now and you're making I
don't know can you just look over there
for one second so I can get my thoughts
together go ahead God okay just give me
I feel like I just got lit like I feel
like I got lit like that's the only
thing I feel like he just held up there
no you just make me nervous sometimes
because I love you I'm trying to
articulate this well which is and I just
think I'm comforting no it I think I'm
comforting
me no it's just give me a second so do
they know like do you have an angle
where this guy is on camera no so it's
just a voice no zyde came in he's
working on the roast with me he's gonna
go write all the roasts with me we're
doing the road oh so we're multitasking
right now well no he's also just my
friend no I know he's your friend but
people can't see him right I just I want
to say that I thought it was really cool
we are not on the microphone and no one
but he's not even on the camera it's
just a voice more even
oh yeah there's a camera oh that's what
I'm just saying I'm just saying there's
a voice coming from under the table
people are gonna go I saw you on Whitney
it's amazing what you're able to do with
your testicles he's the guy that I pay
to eat my pussy under the table I just
meant to say that it was really cool to
hear that conversation pay you to do
that
I wouldn't do that out of the goodness
of your heart no it's um it was really
cool to hear the conversation about
respect and Comedians and um can I say
one more thing that's a great statement
after I said you wouldn't eat her pussy
yeah why are you bombing on purpose
that's my entire act yeah no but let me
tell you something so I was doing the
roast this is circuit is fine that's
what podcasts are nice if you want
something written go see something
written these are free bitch give me a
second yeah so I was doing the roast it
was not the roast I had written on the
roast before I did Joan River so I wrote
on Saget I wrote on a bunch and then I
was watching Greg drawled on one of my
favorites one of the most that's the
Geraldo one of the most brilliant roast
joke writers of all time he I was
working on the roast of uh Flavor Flav
the reason I got the job was I did the
joke flave you look like what Magic
Johnson should look like right now oh my
God I love that such a good joke right
and then a great joke and then they had
to give me the job because they wanted
to use that joke and then I just like
you know and so I was working on stroke
for all the other ones that other people
came up with I was like I have a better
version of that and until fucking
Geraldo Geraldo opened up with uh for
iced tea iced tea is so old he used his
first residual check to buy his freedom
my God perfect perfect joke right so
he's like the gr I mean just a brilliant
comedian he was a lawyer before that
like it's like I didn't know that just
hold no respect all these communities
are just trash Dimitri Martin was a
lawyer you know there's like you know
brilliant guy and he had a lot of Pilots
that didn't go as all of us did you know
Ryan Bialik is a neuroscientist yes yes
she um studies primarily oxytocin right
yeah it has nothing to do with this
conversation no I just wanted to add
something go ahead
I'm fascinated by her uh for many
reasons but um and she's lovely
so on to people that aren't lovely um so
Geraldo is on the red carpet and uh
talking to you know whatever The
Correspondents that are trying to be
funny with him whatever but the Slams on
him because you never could say it
wasn't funny he's like duh you were on
this GT version
I'm sorry I'm stuttering today
you're on this TV show it got canceled
like you out all these Pilots that
didn't go you guys we should finish up
this roast because as soon as they see
geraldo's on it they're going to cancel
you know it's like every joke was about
his failed TV career right he's a
brilliant stand-up and destroys the rose
and he's going down the red carpet and
someone was like so like what do you
feel about the fact like everyone always
makes fun of your TV girl like you
haven't anybody and someone trying to be
funny and he just went when did it
become so embarrassing to just be a
comedian for a living but that's he just
said it and it wasn't he wasn't trying
to make a joke he's like I'm confused
surgeons come up to me and are like I
could never do that man like what you do
is incredible and it's like I bet your
TV show didn't go like the talent is
like one percent of why the show didn't
go like what you know so it was just
like this I saw that and I'm so glad I
saw him say that because I think I would
have given up if I didn't but I love
Comedians and I love comedy and I have
so much respect for everyone who does it
and there's nobody that does it that
I've seen that whether I
um triggered or laugh at whatever but I
knowing what are you eating candy corn
just
I don't know
go ahead I don't
she's just eating do you want one no
okay well you're gonna be talking
I planned it out for when you were
talking so is you not on camera now
no I'm only on camera you're off camera
the whole show so it's just it's just
it's just you snacking do you remember
police at Police Academy the guy that
was out of frame yeah and you never saw
his face because he was too tall so you
just have one candy corn while I'm
talking I forgot what I was gonna say
you're eating you're snacking
I don't I've never seen that I've never
it's not a bad thing it's just very and
it's unconventional it is you have where
did you pull it out of I have a bag of
candy corn
there was just candy corn there I love
candy corn but I saw you come in you
weren't carrying candy corn yeah it's
pre-placed I have a whole stash of weird
shit over here
and I just take a little candy corn
while you're talking and then I do this
with the mic so they won't hear it
wow that's like a little behind the
scenes it's a little bit of my
um solution to my ADD autism where I I
do have a problem I get excited and I
interrupt people you have low blood
sugar but it's more if I know you're
about to tell I'll just chew put
something in my mouth so I don't
interrupt
that stops you from interrupting eating
like just a little eating but I know but
eating if you would
eating is interrupting no I I think it
is like it's snack I hear the crinkling
of paper and I see you put something in
your mouth
was bad
like someone's laughing and I opened up
who was laughing well now they're
laughing at you eating they're not
laughing because it's the the flow ruin
the flow would you like a candy corn no
are you sure yeah I just said that Greg
Geraldo asked when did it become so
embarrassing to just be a comedian for a
living no that's not that what that
that's that line was that when you read
your love comedians you were saying I
love comedians I love that I love that
in the middle of your podcast you have a
recap yeah like it doesn't even end yet
we're recapping there's a snack break
along with it it is like reminiscing
like too soon
isn't it it's like is it considered
reminiscing if what we're talking about
just happened like a second ago you know
what I was talking about
this is what a podcast you just started
podcasting Howie I've been doing this
for a while I don't snap the whole point
is you can do whatever the fuck you want
was that my camera he's hit he's blocked
every camera he's hitting cameras he's
rolling around the floor you're eating
this is the most fucked up Podcast no
it's it's so weird we're in a little
room my guy Rich who's been with me for
30 years you let him you make him I
don't know if they could see him from
the end but you put him in a corner why
would you put him nobody puts Richie in
the corner maybe yeah Richie you got a
timeout can you go get me some water
yeah go sit in a corner with a portrait
of me I also loved it there's a portrait
of you right he has to sit under the
portrait of you yeah yeah no we know and
sit in the Whitney corner
and then you have a bald man on the
floor there's some guy you know what is
that is that like a pantry is that where
you get your snacks he's the snack maven
anyway what was she saying go ahead
we'll continue what I love about this is
it was during you talking about how much
you love comedians am I fucking too much
and then we're acting like complete
assholes and I love him I don't think
I'm being an asshole
I love you we make it hard for people to
love us oh good for finishing the
question okay to stay you know what I
love about you I this nothing is funnier
to me than you because you there's
nothing no this is why comedians are so
great nothing gets past them nothing it
was a problem right yeah my wife I've
been married for 42 years she goes bless
her you have to fucking comment on
everything why are you snacking I had
one half a sentence Did you think I had
a paragraph like where how are you
timing this
because it's you're not seeing what I'm
seeing it's distracting a little bit
okay
not insulted that I that I I have wet
your appetite
foreign
so we did have when I did Howie's
podcast we got to this place and he's
like I would I make you wet and then of
course I start bawling crying on his
podcast so it was wet on the other side
of them
but the point is uh I'm this is going to
be two sentences if you want a snack go
ahead no but what the point is the
camera's on something the camera's on
you I want to leave it on you let's
listen to me you when you're talking the
singles on you but you know what I'm
gonna no one sees it can we cut this go
do it just have it on you and don't even
cut to me I'll talk and so they could
see what it's like you know to be me why
don't you grab one and throw try to
throw it in my mouth and we'll have
Justice why does that make it justice
you don't want from my fingers to your
mouth yeah I do I I pay for it
this is oh see that was out of it yeah
because you hit it so there hasn't the
camera hasn't been pointed for the last
10 minutes oh no
you're on three uh I'm not a group not
overhand okay well what do you mean
underhand what am I a softball pitcher
oh okay I don't know how do you do it
underhand from a table I don't know
yeah
that's what you put it in your own mouth
okay every time I take a bite you can
throw a tomato how about that I'm trying
to work on things to manage my add to
not interrupt because when I get excited
and I start to go I like your
interrupting I like your energy it's not
rude it's not rude the fans don't love
it how do you know because they want to
hear you talk those aren't the fans they
want me to fans are here for you and I'm
here for you we're all here for you
because it's good for you
you don't say good for us
you know bad bad bad yeah oh bad you
didn't finish you didn't swallow
everything did you you had something
that no it's okay eat I never I feel
like I'm interrupting your snack no I
laughs
this is I feel bad I don't want your
sugar to drop I'm working on not
interrupting and the way the only way
you can work on it is jamming shit in
your mouth I basically like so if you're
on a date will you put his dick in your
mouth just so you know it's not that I
want to blow you I don't want to
interrupt you
because you probably have some things
you want to say so I'm just going to
suck on this and you tell me all about
yourself and your history and what you
want out of this relationship I would
rather suck your dick than listen to
your stories
how does sucking his dick stop the
stories
oh did I tell you what I I gotta tell
you I remember I have very big teeth
when I'm sucking a man's dick he's
really trying not to move at all
you chew
no I just have really big teeth I know I
think it's kind of like putting your
dick in a shark's mouth you kind of
don't want to move around too much why
would anybody put their dick in a
shark's mouth
comedy
this is one of my favorite so Norm
Macdonald he was on Roseanne oh when I
was out making the reboot with everyone
the room is incredible Wanda Sykes was
in the room you know it was just magical
um and uh Norm was there and I was
Norm's the best I was like I'll take any
iteration of Norm if it's an hour a day
if he calls in zoo I don't care like
we'll take he was writing or he was
going to be on in the room oh wow in the
writer's room and we had him once a week
as like a consulted twice a week as a
consultant and there are a bunch of
people that worked on Norm sitcom uh you
know Bruce Halford and I were you know
writing it together so Bruce uh Halford
ran uh his sitcom and worked on The
Originals Roseanne whatever and I was
like so what's it like working with Norm
like in a writer's room like I'm such a
big fan I've done roasts with him
whatever like and they go it's kind of
like trying to give a cat a bath like
you would pop in he would pop out it was
we'd follow him around be like do you
have a pitch for the you know he's just
in his um
world and uh one time he pitched
something that was so funny and
Brilliant and then there was a writer in
the room that was like yeah but like
what does that mean like you know would
she really say that in this environment
it was really trying to pick it apart
like how is that motivated and does that
really uh make is that specific to their
relationship like why exactly would you
know he say that and he goes oh um
because
comedy I love that I love that
that's how you talk to a network exactly
maybe because comedy and we're like did
everybody laugh it was about it Mary say
my favorite like one of my favorite
jokes from his last special the one that
he made what did you think of that I
loved it it was so I loved it also it
took me a couple times to watch it I
cried too much that's what I'm saying it
was just incredibly sad but incredibly
raw it was like watching the most
beautiful comedic acapella performance
and because he hadn't done it for
audiences like he was cracking himself
up and he didn't cut anything that
audiences didn't get but knowing where
he was in his life he was going in the
next morning for surgery
that's pretty amazing what we're talking
about he summed it up perfectly in that
special he goes what's this new thing
where like people look to comedians for
like morality and politics and our
opinion like people look to us you know
like when uh Vietnam was happening was
everyone like I wonder what Red Skeleton
thinks like we're idiots like why but
the truth is that they do look to people
in Show Business that we were talking
about that earlier I think that's
changing I think post the pandemic
people are like we do not want to hear
celebrities fucking talk well you say
that the celebrities are different
they're now called influencers because
they influence under the influencer
under the influence of fucking
narcissism but because uh somebody has
some modicum of uh popularity and I
don't even know if they're really
popular but a lot of people know who
that one person is yeah we believe that
we should listen to them we should look
like them I think as soon as a celebrity
who isn't a comedian post their
political opinions people are done it's
over like I think that's because it's so
device if you lose half your audience
yeah and it just doesn't feel like this
isn't where you're qualified to know
about like we want you know I think that
um especially given what happened in the
pandemic with so many people losing
their savings losing their jobs the idea
of a bunch of rich people in mansions
telling you you know talking about
anything it's just like just be pretty
just dress up for us your job is to
distract us it's not to make us think
about problems that you would never know
how to how to solve and frankly don't
even have so I think I mean just from
touring all over the country it's Comics
like we go and we meet people like this
and they're like thank you for not I
always say that that's why I love that
you're in rooms of shows because I think
that traveling all over the country
really gives you kind of a a feeling of
your you know you're on the pulse
because living here in Los Angeles or
New York or being in an executive office
at a network or uh you know a streamer I
don't know that the people that you sell
to it's mostly Harvard guys
whether it's Margaret guys whether it's
when you live this is a bubble that is
is nothing like the rest of the country
you know and and they don't even talk
like we're talking in the whole country
and a lot of the problems within the
industry
that are fucked up are not happening in
America you know and so they happen in
your industry don't ruin good shows
because you guys did creepy gross shit
you know what I mean like we can still
laugh at stuff like I remember when the
time's up in me too stuff first started
my not that special but the last special
I talked a lot about at the moment the
robot right and um I had written because
I was in LA at the time writing and I'm
in this just Echo Chamber Of La I'm in
this bubble and I'm like oh my God
sexual harassment is the biggest problem
I gotta write about this is what
everyone's talking about I go to Houston
I think it was yeah I I didn't know you
yet I was just working on new stuff and
I opened with um you know the uh I did a
joke that was about Aziz because the
Aziz thing uh that really bothered me
well that was just but that's not her
you know that's uh you know bother me
even more no is that no Comics defended
him because they but that woman on CNN
did what's her name he somebody came to
his rescue Megan Kelly no no that's
another network but but uh she has the
glasses
no no
I saw she did this thing where she
talked about you know what this woman is
describing is a bad date you know or a
misunderstanding I don't understand but
I thought that was great that you can
feel that way like that's I know what
it's like to be you know 22 and 23 and
to feel that way but um feelings aren't
facts and what he did it's just you know
that was like the Tipping Point of like
you know for me in comedy which is like
you I think sometimes comedians were so
pitted against each other there's such a
scarcity complex and sometimes
especially younger Comics they look at
really successful Comics or once it made
it really early and they go like the
only way I'm gonna succeed is if you get
knocked out right you know but it was
like had Comics support a disease which
I know a lot of people he rubs a lot of
people the wrong way that's just some
people do I'm sure I do too you know I'm
nervous and anxious at parties and you
know people project you know the first
couple times I met Aziz I'm like that's
kind of a dick and then I got to know
him and I was like oh no I was just
insecure and he was insecure and it just
you know and so a lot of people didn't
defend him and it was like if you guys
don't rally around him you are next
we're setting the precedent that this is
okay to take someone's job over this is
totally inappropriate and like you know
uh but I had a joke about it I was like
I just heard about this like thing that
happened with a famous comedian he took
this girl out to dinner they had some
wine they went back to his place and I
was like who is this Prince Charming
like it was sort of about like is he
available in that like thank God he's
canceled because now I have a shot like
it was sort of about you know that and
then I was talking about sexual
harassment in the office
um and talking about you know coming up
in writer's room with comedians I'm like
I'm part of this problem like we would
run past each other and like put hands
between our butts and be like I was
swiping a credit card like I I thought
it was hilarious you know and then I
know that's funny I don't think I would
do that as a germaphobe you swiped with
somebody like a fellow person's hat like
you would put your fingers into you're
the person to ask about this okay do you
wash your jeans
yeah do you never do you don't most men
don't wash their jeans that's not true
do you wash your jeans every four days
so what are you talking you wash your
jeans well you have to what but you know
what what about him do you wash your
jeans
I I do wash my jeans so there are there
are four guys one woman in this room
every one of us where did you get this
Theory I will accuse you of rape
be my guest to continue why wouldn't
guys wash their hands I have this power
for another six months and I'm gonna use
it no a lot of guys don't wash their
jeans because they think it messes up
that look I've dated mostly gay men I
realize that now wait wait why don't
they wash their jeans because you know
the new jeans that are like 200 jeans
were supposed to be 40 they're now like
designer jeans they're like 200. these
are expensive jeans 300 but they say
you're not supposed to a lot of guys put
them in the freezer or keep them fresh
don't wash them why would you put your
jeans in the fridge to kill the bacteria
so that you don't have to put them in
the water because at least so then you
wear them out of the fridge them it
shrinks them well then if you but if you
take your jeans out of the freezer and
put them on it shrinks other things I
wouldn't want Frozen jeans around my
nuts
I know someone by the way a comedian um
a friend of mine that hooked up with a
pretty famous comedian like TV guy and
when she came over she had to put her
purse in the freezer
because he didn't want germs purses are
gross I mean purses you put them on the
ground so why would you want them where
you put your food that's right keep my
jeans
I don't know really yeah I'm just so he
you get a young lady to to I'm like to
come home and you want to fuck her in
the ass like pic of phobia like this is
not adding up but did he did he fuck her
in the freezer
he should fuck her in the freezer
make sure the nipples are hard her
pussy's tight there's no that instead of
wearing protection what I need you to do
I'm going to insert let me go get the
ice maker I'm gonna
taking a quick break because now a word
from our sponsor better help the great
thing about better help is that you can
switch counselors based on the way
you're able to process things in the way
you're able to like hear things and you
know some people I for a long time went
to therapists that like I try to
manipulate and lie to because they
didn't talk to me like I was an adult
you know I I you know a lot of people
want someone who's gentle and I'm like I
don't want that just tell me what to do
it's like well it's you know a lot of
therapists would say to me which I think
a lot of people need like it's premature
like you know let's go through it I was
like just tell me and um this therapist
I work for for ages was like you're not
going home for Christmas she's a bitch
and I'm like got it okay thank you and
there's a lot of I would complain I was
so stuck on this X and I couldn't stop
talking about him because what happened
was like unfair and I just thought the
more I talked about it the more people
would help me or something and finally
she goes you don't get to talk to about
him for 30 days you're addicted to
talking about him we need to minimize
essentially the neural pathway that goes
to that on a loop constantly you're in
an obsession like you don't get to talk
about this in therapy and then I just
sat there was like
okay what are we what should we put on a
podcast or oh my God it was and that
changed my life you know so that's the
kind of therapist I need I don't you
know but everybody's brain works
differently you know so that's what's so
great about this it's convenient it's
accessible it's affordable entirely
online get matched with the therapist
after filling out a brief survey and
switch therapists anytime you want and
if you can't switch therapists because
you feel guilty
that's something to look at
when you want to be a better person a
better Problem Solver therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com Whitney
today to get 10 off your first month it
will change your life it will change
your relationships you will start
getting everything you want and realize
that a lot of the obstacles in your life
are not as big as you think they are
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Whitney better help is
to take care of the inside of your head
but the outside of your head matters too
hair is so much more than physical
appearance for women it shapes our
relationship with ourselves from the
inside out it defines our identity our
self-image not that I at all like Define
my value through my hair and here's what
I will say sorry first of all female
hair loss is a reality for millions of
women yet most are reluctant to discuss
it publicly if you see a woman in a
stupid hat
probably what's going on okay like all
those women that go to the derby I'm
like I know what this is neutrophil is
looking to unite and support women
through the personal impacts of female
hair struggles like thinning and
shedding by creating a space to connect
share and bond no pun intended with
others neutral Volvo like to open up a
larger conversation through real women
sharing real stories about how their
hair struggles have impacted them your
hair story could help another woman join
the conversation at nutriful.com
shed the silence and talk about your
experience share it neutral full I take
this I take these are the supplements I
take it has completely changed my life
changed my hair because remember my
thing is right now I'm just growing my
hair out and then I'll get rid of these
and look at how much thicker this is my
hair this has grown so much faster
because remember I um for about two and
a half years
um like lived in a vat of bleach
uh and dyed my hair every single color
under the sun
um because uh it's called coping
um and so now my hair this is mine it's
finally starting to grow back and it's
like super healthy and thick it's wild
so thank you for that neutralfold now I
actually have a hair that I can pull out
is cold you think boiling things would
kill bacteria well to say can you put
your purse in a boil a pot of boiling
water that's tough like it's easy to go
I'm just gonna put your purse in the
freezer like all the tampons would
be used up
Frozen tampons have you ever inserted a
frozen tampon I haven't
I'm from Canada all women there do
wait there's something I want to well
one thing about Carson that I wanted to
just write down and not interrupt you
about something that changed my life
that he said because I also want to ask
you about him because I think it's kind
of a complicated Legacy and I'm just
curious because I am obsessed with Joan
Rivers you know as you are too we she
gave me probably my biggest bump in life
maybe me too yeah she put a Tonight Show
she put me on The Tonight Show I told
you that story right yes yes so she put
me on The Tonight Show I couldn't get on
The Tonight Show and then uh Carson saw
me with her and and requested me and I
did it 22 times
wild
um so he said something uh wait don't
start the story
[Laughter]
not sound like that I did not sound like
that I did not sound like that I have
misophonia so when someone is chewing it
drives me fucking nuts do you hear it
right so you just swallow that hole
if people are just tuning in now she's
talking about uh something one of these
did you chew that that fast it's a
little candy yes not enough juice
fuck is wrong with you how many choose
how many of you are Jewish Jewish I see
what you did there that was like three
chops and then swallow
probably but it's just a little candy
it's just this that was not enough so
three how much would you chew this okay
just do it
one two three all right you need to do
more that's not enough it's not ready to
swallow here you go it's not this is bad
for your colon no chew it more going
chew it
you're a bad shoe
I knew there you're gonna be feeling
that later you know what you can't you
tried to prove a point to me and
ultimately you're gonna be home tonight
being like that was nice
traditionally Jews are not known for
swallowing
um where did you find a Kroger pack
Kroger Ross it says Kroger that's who
owns it Kroger owns Ralph's yes it's
Ralphs okay yeah did you just wink at me
[Music]
it doesn't bother me unless it's like
you're dumb that way that was like is
that what you take from a wink well no
it's like when someone says bless your
heart and you realize later it's because
they think you're dumb he gave me a wink
like don't worry
I won't let anyone know how dumb you are
that's what that Wing was why is that
the lit why is that the the criteria
like you don't know the corporate
structure of a of a grocery chain you
idiot you idiot you're a fucking idiot
do you not know that Krogers
fucking idiot by the way somebody who
has to purchase as many snacks as you
intake how the fuck do you not know who
the parent company oh Jesus
also you just proved my point the other
day I proved a point from another day
men cannot not pluralize companies why
is it it's Kroger is that Kroger's
Kroger's owns it's not
drums
I didn't say Nordstrom
why are you taking your plurals out on
me you said I'm Roger asshole did he say
did he say how do you say asshole in
Sign Language uh did you not say Krogers
did he not say Kroger's
yes but it was it was the Krogers it
what do you call it ownership when you
have apostrophe yes did you say crow
it's Kroger I don't know I think he said
Kroger's Kroger Kroger's
this is the exact Hill I will die on but
this is bad this isn't even worth
stopping and reminiscing about this
moment of this podcast this is not worth
a recap
this is it was okay I need a tooth cap
after eating that chewing that as much
as I did I just realized well you chew
too much and you expect too much chewing
of others
forcing a guest to chew you've seen my
teeth I only need to chew once and it's
handled you know but other people have
beautiful teeth when I relieve
relationship I'm like I don't know what
happened I think I just chewed too much
I can't tell if you love me or hate me I
love you I
know something Johnny said is he said
every B joke in stand-up is an a joke
extemporaneously so anything that didn't
work on stage is a stand-up like
necessarily it's not good enough to be
in your act if you come up with it on
the spot in an interview it's an a joke
does that make sense yes because you'll
never not use a joke you wrote even if
it doesn't make it so I write all these
jokes and I have all these it'll always
come in handy whether it's now or in 20
years you know right
I still think I chew enough are you
disagreeing with Johnny Carson probably
but he would say like all the jokes that
I wrote that were like B plus jokes all
of a sudden if I say them except rain is
like he was the uh they're a plus Yeah
but I
I feel like you're intentionally being a
contrarian about this I am but isn't
that interesting if I if I just go yeah
you're right then we'll move on to
another topic but if I could find
something I'm trying to make this
episode better than I think it is
can I tell you something you know he
just did this is the perfect gonna
happen because you motherfuckers out
there like this is what conversations
look like when people are like oh I said
something you don't disagree with me
fuck you you don't disagree with me
you're trash it's like what do you want
you want the world to just be a big
huddle where you say like I like this
person I was like me too
I want people to disagree with you I do
I love disagreement because that's what
a discussion is that's a discussion we
forgot about that if if if you say
everything and I go right then it's not
a discussion I'm just listening to you
and responding to you and I think as a
guest on your podcast
I should discuss yes agree otherwise I'm
just sitting like everybody else like
you I'm just sitting like you listening
to her and I am sitting and listening to
her but I'm responding and hopefully
they're listening to us but this is what
every conversation should be whether
it's with your family or friends when
comedians aren't around right like I say
a lot of things that I don't even know
if I agree with I say it we are we us
they them I identify they them you know
what we gotta stick with I here's the
thing
we have to really support the pronouns I
identify as because I would like to get
to a point where I can identify as
invisible
try to talk to me if someone tries to
talk to me I could just like I I'm
invisible you're not like and like oh
sorry because that's how we act when you
misgender someone now we're like sorry I
got that wrong like I feel like we can
use this to our advantage I do things
like I'll give them signals that don't
make sense to make them uncomfortable
like somebody starts saying something to
me and I don't want to be involved in
the conversation and I don't know I'll
go
it doesn't mean anything but I go
and people go
let me walk away and nobody I know they
walk over to wherever they're going and
go I don't know I was saying something
to Howie but they got it they got it
that I didn't want to talk about it so
you start talking to me like say start
talking to me so um like what is going
on over at AGT right now like I feel
like
and then by the way
they're like
I don't think he wanted to talk about it
how do you know he didn't want to talk
about it he went but it was also like
now Howie and I have this secret you
know what I mean and we're like bonded
and I'm keeping like I love having
signals and not sharing them with others
that's like having one walkie-talkie
right the the thing is dude but it works
for some reason it always does anything
Works everything works it's how you
present it if you present it with
confidence and that's especially for
comedy yeah you know I I used to I used
to have Bets with other friends to you
know to go up on stage I'm gonna do a
non-joke I promise you I can get a laugh
it's about now you're texting no I was
just gonna the food is here and you can
grab it I can die snacks I can do you we
had the appetizer the food is here go
get the food
this is like it's a it's not a podcast
it's a fucking Buffet sorry I don't have
a giant Studio that has five restaurants
inside it but what are they texting your
food is here no the Postmates hey maybe
don't slam the door Zion wild well
you're worried about the sound of the
door when you've been eating snacks
you've been taking texts I'm talking
about where Kroger stuff is here there
we go
this is now now the door is just open
we're gonna hear bring Postmates in
bring your postmate in I've done that
before I actually do it a lot you bring
Postmates yeah have you ever conformed
no one wants to be a postmate you know
so it's like I see someone who's like
Young and Hungry weird they're never
hungry because they eat your food I know
that I know people that have done
doordash and Postmates like oh we always
steal the food right I think I know
people who've used postmate as a dating
app
they show up in Teslas I mean right
fahima they have food if you want to go
out to dinner with somebody there they
bring it to you they have a nice car
they're doing exactly what does these
did right they're delivering yes
so
um I can multitask actually pretty well
I have really bad 80d but I kind of can
sometimes do things what else is
happening right now as we're talking I'm
miscarrying currently I know I can tell
but do you think that you have the this
weird I love the the comics
um unique superpowers that kind of no
one else has
um I always know how much time has
elapsed
you know because we're so used to being
on stage and needing to like I break up
time differently than other people I
always know what time it is you know
what time is it though I knew you were
gonna do that no no I didn't I don't
know you said we included me with your
superpower you'd have to tell me when we
started I don't know what time it was I
know I got here early
do you feel like you have that do you
feel like you always kind of know how
much time has allowed I do I do mostly
when I'm uh having sex with my wife
honey it's almost a minute
it's getting close to a minute
gotta go
so I have that uncanny if you manage how
do you have such an incredible healthy
marriage I don't think Comics are famous
for being great in I have a person I
have all kidding aside I have a
superwoman and she just understands your
heart and is like patient with you but
you have you had to work not so much oh
a lot she threatened to lead me before I
got therapy she said it's I'm taking the
kids and going unless you go get help so
I went and got help so it takes us it
takes a village to uh to live with me
I'm not a you know I always say this to
people in the audience when they want to
they go it's great I go you're spending
an hour with me and it seems like fun
yeah and uh it seems like it'd be a joy
to but living with me as I say I'm I'm
good in small doses yes very small doses
and I also don't know when to leave
I'm if you invite me to a party you know
you're going to be in your room going
you go downtown
well I gotta I gotta leave on a closer
and because you guys are bombing I I
gotta go out on a high note so sometimes
that's part of the conversation are you
telling me now that the podcast is over
I don't know if I'm at a party I can't
believe and I don't you don't leave the
stage until you have the biggest laugh I
I feel like I'm wired I can't leave the
party until like something works why you
don't do I do the Irish goodbye always
but I don't leave because I this is
going to sound sociopathic I know but
like I'm very when I'm it's so hard for
me to be social that if I can't find a
way to make it somewhat Justified like
by like like work like I'm kind of an
anthropology like I need to get a good
story out of this and I won't leave
until I have a good story because
otherwise oh so you're writing material
maybe you're waiting I want to see
something or learn something if I just
go to a party and everyone's just kind
of and I don't have an interesting
object I haven't left with an
interesting observation or an
interesting Insight or an interesting
story I will literally stay as long as I
have to
and then they went to sleep yeah and
then they woke up the next morning and
you should see what they had for
breakfast yeah there's nothing there so
I stayed for lunch and then they got so
angry now we're talking now I have a
good two days yeah he went down and came
back up I got my Tonight Show story
thank you so much for the invite like I
just kind of have to you know but I'm
just fascinated by that because I find
that I'm really struggling I was living
with someone and then I'm really hard to
live with because I just I'm very um I
get a lot of my emotional needs met
internally and I need a lot of alone
time and someone can be telling me
something really serious about their day
and I'm like oh my God and then they
think I'm insensitive or it's just so
I'm now not cohabitating and maybe
that'll work but I'm just interested I
don't think my wife listens to me
anymore smart smart woman but I feel
like I like to pretend that she's
listening so I'll tell her the story and
I don't really need uh
because we with a lot of the marriage a
lot of our discussion is honey I told
you and here's the biggest problem
listen when people talk
because we're looking for the mistake
we're looking for the uh inanity of
whatever it is we're looking for the
funny we're always searching so it's not
so much that what you're saying is
interesting it's like what can I get out
of it we have to pick it apart whereas
she's smart most people I think don't
listen to what most people say they're
kind of like half on autopilot and
Zombieland right you know but we
actually hear people and listen and
break it apart and that's how people
don't listen part of our plight yeah
which is good because I know that
ignorance is bliss I think we're a mess
because we heard it we're hearing it and
we can't get over it yeah what's the
thing that has hurt your feelings the
most in your life that someone has said
or someone has like you know we tend to
be kind of Teflon in some ways but I
know that you know people get your
account you're this you're not funny for
many many years uh it doesn't bother me
anymore but because I felt like I wasn't
accepted in the in the comedy community
I felt like I was the the joke I felt
like even Letterman was always my name
came up in the top ten so many times as
the I was made fun of on SNL a bunch
well so was I that kind of that didn't
bother me as much but I just felt when
you don't feel that you're getting
respect from your peers when you don't
have to think I'm funny but sometimes
the more respect you get from the
mainstream the less respect you get from
your peers which is the ultimate mind
fuck right and I think that we are a
sick group that knee needs to be that
wants acceptance from people that we
don't know that we will never know and
to have that need I always wonder what
it what it's like to be the person that
doesn't need to be on camera or on stage
in front of strangers trying to you know
just ultimately scream love me love me
yeah love me so when you feel that and
it was very uh prevalent especially in
the 70s at The Comedy Store
um you know the dislike you want to you
want a snack no I was
oh you wanna you want me to write down
what I'm saying yeah could you just take
notes for me thanks all right no I just
I had a pen and I want to write
something down there's so many things
here forget it I'm noticing your table
too are you gonna clip your nails I know
it's the nail clipper I have a pretty
serious
um OCD thing with digging out
um like
ingrowns
really and I sprinkle them around the
carpet I'm joking I have a pen you saw a
pen no no I have one I have one I'm
sorry I'm being professional no you
don't have it oh I see it right there
you yeah but I have another one that
someone probably threw of me oh my God
and while I'm down here girl
do you need a pen I'm just looking okay
what were you saying what is this stuff
what what
are you on um can I ask where you're on
you don't have to tell me
what about uh Zoloft well because I had
something fascinating happen to me where
I do have like
Moroccan oil it's a very awesome
hairspray you don't need it you know
what when I first moved to LA I was
really good friends with Jennifer Love
Hewitt she did something that changed my
life okay so Jennifer Love Hewitt taught
me this trick
Hairspray
God damn it
here I have something thank you
thank you so much Moroccan oil promo
code Whitney
um manifesting so Jennifer Love Hewitt
taught me this when I first moved to LA
like because you know famous actors have
all the most incredible beauty secrets
right so she took some hairspray and she
went on a finger
I like that
what's I don't know what happened keep
your eyebrows in place well you just
offended every gay man watching
why
what do you mean what I am a gay man no
but you know you did right
all the death oh my God
all the deaf your brain is a fucking
super computer
yeah well I'm not I'm just I want to be
I want everybody to love this episode
and I know that every deaf gay man just
went fucked it
no
I'm your brain is just cutting that up
brain is just unbelievable okay it's so
unbelievable thank you I was just gonna
ask because I went you know we have
these kind of what does that do what did
you do it just put there wasn't a
difference no I don't know I I the fact
that what you did you believe changed
your life
the fuck I mean that's what's getting me
more than there is no fucking difference
do you you have now you have your
eyebrows look exactly the same as they
did a second ago and you have one sticky
finger this is not a life-changing
moment for anybody
well now it'll stay this way like you
can come on my eyebrows and then we'll
move around you know they won't because
is that a porn trick is that what the
girls in foreign
if I do this while I'm talking to you
and my eyebrows are gonna go up like the
fucking Joker people already think I'm
not gonna do I would imagine the same
thing would happen if you had come on
your finger and you did that yeah I
could do it that way but you know I
swallow because I'm just a cum guzzler
is that your nickname
but here's Jose people already think I
look like Don merkels I don't need to
fucking do this so that my eyebrows go
up well you don't look nothing like Don
Rickles why would you use that as a you
exaggerate for a living too
stop intentionally pretending you think
I'm serious
this is why I love Comics I just love
hangout with Comics it's just const you
just get constant shit it reminds me I'm
not giving you shit I don't I just I'm
not giving you any shit I'm not you're
the best I really uh respect you I love
what you've done I don't know if you
talk about it but that's I'm so bowled
over I know you probably don't want to
talk about it by ear but first of all I
love your career and I love what you do
and you're one of the most prolific
people I've ever met and as far the
camera will be on you during this
so as you listen to this she is eating a
fucking ton of shit
no what is that what's the speed no I'm
just saying if well it's on me they
don't know what's there you know what's
funny as you I was just saying and you
have the most gorgeous house and great
taste thank you I also noticed that as
you were walking but I don't taste great
every room you mentioned I just want
this to be comfortable I don't care
about coasters I haven't been in one
room without coasters you have coasters
everywhere you have more coasters not
used the drinks are all over the place
there's there's Starbucks but you have
Stacks and stacks
in every room I've never seen Pat
lavazar and it's pissing me off I'm
saying every room had coasters every
fucking room had a stack of unused
coasters you must I don't care about
coasters they're not used you have a
stack of coasters I know every Cup every
cup is there's nothing near here's
another coaster look there's another
coaster good for you you have another
you are exactly correct
um I don't I my friends are fucking
animals I'm trying to train them to use
coasters but it's gonna be how do you
train them the guy that came in and said
hey if you want to drink something here
it is and he jammed it on the table and
then started sleeping on the floor no
that was the other guy there's another
guy that you sent up to he said I'm
gonna be in the Attic
oh okay yeah that's my stalker he lives
in the Attic he says I have to go do
something in the Attic here's the here's
the thing yeah and and I would imagine
if you go up to the addict right now
there's a guy attic basically addict is
it he's on coke so yeah he'd go up to
the attic right now he's probably in the
dark hoveled over cutting out coasters
for more rooms she has a coaster maker
fucking coasters Whitney wants coasters
I love I grew up in a home that was very
messy and very sloppy I know but you
have stacks of fucking coasters
everywhere they're not under cups
and they're really good they're
personalized coasters every one of these
coasters those fans sent those are fan
scent the ones I have with horses that's
my horse yeah that's your horse and this
is fans send you coaster of me and my
horse yeah no you're in your horse yeah
yeah yeah that's nice look at that we're
gonna take a little break Roman swipes
they are convenient over-the-counter
wives that are incredible what they
basically do is that they help you last
longer in bed this is genius uniquely
formulated reduce overstimulation
without eliminating sensation altogether
otherwise they're just you know
just use the lightsaber you know in 2019
there was a study that they were proven
increased time to orgasm by more than
four times all swipe orders include free
uh uh stuff two oh two day shipping and
they arrive in are they gonna say
unmarked packaging this is we couldn't
find this product for a while they sent
it to us this is how it's sent to you
your neighbors won't know this is a
miracle this solved that problem I feel
like this is going to reduce
fights in relationships by like 40
percent this is a game changer I'm so
excited try swipes today with our
special offer just for our listeners and
the gals that listen to us they get can
get guys off fast because they're smart
and they're funny and I love them all
and then guys you want to be a fucking
stud in bed here you go get 20 off your
first order to get Roman uh.com slash
good get roman.com good your slash
deserves it it is time to upgrade your
sleep you are in your bed most of the
time blissy I have talked to you guys
about silk pillowcases it is the best
thing on the planet for your skin
because what happens is you're getting
in bed and all the products you put on
it is just absorbing that and it's also
giving you wrinkles everyone should be
having
um silk pillowcases I agree they've been
pretty trash until now so Blissey
figured it out they have an
award-winning uh 100 Mulberry silk
pillowcases okay and I put one of them I
mean they're in my bag had and I had one
and I put it on the ground and Pat look
how Mona just went over to it
my dog is like curled up on the blissy
pillowcase look and she fell right
asleep
I don't know there's no other way to
show how incredible this pillowcase is
to me this is just like you know you
can't say a dog's full of shit like dogs
don't lie I don't care
um uh she's not getting paid for this
like this is the best endorsement on the
planet you can say goodbye to wrinkly
skin in the morning and wake up with
healthier and shinier hair and that you
can be proud of blissey's pillowcases
regulate temperature keeping you cool at
night I a hot pillow makes me
homicidal it is so rude okay this the
silk pillowcase it's always like ah just
like a little bit cool like ah just and
I get migraines so I have to have the
pillow be a little bit cool anyway I
take these on the road with me entire
pillow is cool to the touch no more
sweaty nights spent toss it and turning
as you search for the cool side oh you
gotta flip it remember you like flip it
and then you flip it again an hour later
but it's still hot and you're just
flipping your pillowcase and then you're
just like I'm up I guess
I hope whoever started this company is
someone that just was like flipping they
were like I'm just gonna invent this
thing because no one else will Blissey
pillowcases are made of 100 Mulberry
silk which I already said but it is
hypoallergenic dogs aren't that's fake
but this can be so you can sleep more
comfortably without itching uh or rashes
and uh I didn't know there were rashes
from pillows I've had a silk pillowcase
for so long that I've never I don't even
know what this shit is and unlike other
silk pillowcases they are machine
washable and durable durable with the
holidays to surrounding Corner why not
give the gift of better sleep plus it
comes in a gift ready packaging that
they'll be sure to love I bring it with
me everywhere
um that's why we never have it in the
studio but it comes in the cutest box
and right now the one extra one I had my
uh my dog is sleeping on and we're gonna
have to insert that video I love you
guys everyone loves blissy they have a
ton of different prints and colors they
make
um uh great gifts because there's an
option for everyone they have literally
over a million raving fans online and if
anyone likes anything online you know it
has to be way better than good try now
risk-free for 60 nights at blissey.com
Whitney and get an additional 30 off
that's blissy Bliss
Whitney and use promo code Whitney to
get an additional 30 off look how
healthy my hair is look how healthy my
skin is none of it's genetic my genetics
are trash so you do the math sometimes
the fear is going blank
that's my probably my biggest fear I
heard on uh recently Dana Gould told a
story on Marin about how he early on
went on Conan and blacked out and went I
don't know what I'm going to say next
and they end up cutting it and like
fixing it you know and I think he
started over but Conan was like you
better be glad you did that on my show
you know they didn't air it but like wow
how terrifying have you ever gone blank
on stage
no
I have but I my ACT is such there where
I go look be honest with you I don't
know what I'm doing right now wait I did
have a nightmare happen in Phoenix as if
that's not traumatic enough uh I'm on
stage this was like a New Year's show
maybe this was like 12 years ago and I
got like thrown by something like there
was someone getting kicked out and there
was like a saga and someone like ran up
on stage and you know something and I
tried to like regroup because I was
actually scared and I started a joke I
had already done
I had like I went into like oh and I
went home for Christmas and this
happened and then I realized what was
happening and they looked confused and I
was able to rescue it but I genuinely
started I had forgotten I had done a
certain joke and just went into it I've
done that a lot I've did it usually when
I used to do two shows a night I would
forget that I did that already and then
halfway through whatever I was telling
they'd go you already told us that I go
I know I know but if it works go with it
again you enjoyed it did you not enjoy
it sometimes dude Domino's Pizza is
better the second time the second day
right you know like so I've learned the
play I always say that to people that
come on AGT if it's going bad or you get
a buzzer or the crowd isn't responding
kind of try to live in the moment you
know try to you know not that you have
to comment about it going bad but find
something in that moment to make it real
and and you'll connect with the audience
and I learned and if the audience knows
you know
they're with you the biggest fear is I'm
watching this ice skater who's about to
fought like put me at ease so I don't
have to worry about you is if you just
go why am I bombing with this and like
then they're like okay she knows now we
can actually Focus because they're so
worried about the fact that you might
not know I know so I I want to relate
we're all human and we as comedians you
know kind of celebrate our foibles and
if you are having a foible share the
foible and uh well it'll makes you
fallible if you stutter as long as you
acknowledge it they'll be fine so if
you're like I did earlier I was um like
uh you know when you just have a great
burn you always do but you like stutter
on it or like it's pronounce something
wrong you're like fuck it totally kills
everything the person I was trying to
roast I just roasted Myself by
embarrassing myself like I said
something earlier about like you know
guys like I was like on a rant about
like guys the way they dress in La it's
like they got like man bun and a v-necks
and your necklace and you got a Roser a
nice rosary and I was just and I went
Rosalie
now just turn into that don't pretend it
didn't happen everyone heard it right
you know and this applies to people that
are not just stand ups like you know
people now they're always having to give
speeches on zooms and you know
presenting their on Shark Tank whatever
like everyone can I think learn from the
things that stand-ups mistakes have
figured out mistakes need to be
celebrated right do we only get the
respect we deserve when we are dead
you know I think that the key and it's
kind of like Mental Health
I think the that's a good question I
don't know the answer I just I think
well I think that people you don't know
what you have until it's gone but I
don't think that anybody feels like the
cool kid yeah I don't think any human
being I think as much as you think
whoever is that cool kid
I would imagine if you were inside the
mind of the cool kid they are trying so
hard to be the cool kid so that they
because they don't feel they're worthy
of being uh you know or they're too
afraid to fail so they don't try at all
right I mean we're all whether you're
the the president of a bank and you're
showing up in a you know in a five
thousand dollar suit with a silk tie you
know you're wearing this fucking costume
that's really uncomfortable that
wouldn't be your choice just so somebody
whatever somebody's you want somebody's
opinion you need somebody's opinion you
can't look like you want to be
comfortable you can't show up in
attraction because then you're giving
the other person power if you are look
like it's all this internal work that we
we were we're always doing but what you
learn at this stage of life is that
ultimately all the respect you need it
has to come from within and all the love
you need has to come from within
happiness is an inside job it really is
happiness and self-worth and uh you know
just uh your own what's your biggest
fear like you're defining fear I know
what mine is now and it masqueraded as
other things for the longest time like I
just didn't know and I actually think
that this is pretty Universal and we all
run around with this but it's not
identified properly like what's your
biggest fear death
interesting why
it's gonna happen though for sure that's
why so there's no stopping it it's like
I'm on this track and this fucking
freight train have you read anything
about Terror management Theory
Terror management Theory
um the the sort of like preeminent book
on it it's called um the worm at the
core by Ernest Becker and it's about how
because humans we are the only species
that has like a keen understanding that
we're gonna die that we're living in
constant Terror right and everything
that we do is uh uh basically to try to
have like some modicum of immortality
it's why we love trophies it's why we
love family crests it's why we you know
like to be on teams and you know have
rings from our college and you know
stuff like that because we're so
uniquely like we're just managing our
own Terror and we have to distract
ourselves uh in a way that is really I
know I'm terrified right now because you
informed me that I ingested yellow
number six
good for me
um my biggest fear in life is being
embarrassed and I you know what the
dichotomy of that is everybody's biggest
fear they said public speaking is the is
the biggest fear but somebody who has
that fear
it would be easier you would think
to hide you've got you've got everything
but that's even more embarrassing you're
a coward like for you know yeah no but
if nobody noticed you and nobody could
judge you and nobody could see you you
have the capacity to be fruitful in
other avenues in a weird way I think
that
when I started doing stand-up it was a
way to hide because I'm hiding behind
this tough ass exterior
front of the fucking world who sees the
way you look sees the way you sound and
judges what you're talking about and I
heard this um kind of changed my life
that comedians become comedians to
control how they're embarrassed I know
it's gonna happen let me at least get to
it before they do I'm a piece of shit
changed your life hearing that well no I
mean more than getting that sticky
finger and rubbing it on your eyebrows
because you said that was life-changing
too so I'm I'm learning that you know
you're using that life-changing kind of
analogy very Loosely and it's got a
broad spectrum of what is life changed
your life
the thing that changed my life most was
becoming a parent and I know that sounds
really boring but uh the truth is that I
thought that I would grow up have kids
and be able to teach them about the
world nothing was more terrifying than
becoming apparent than terrified well
because it's enough to be responsible
for yourself but to be responsible for
another human being for their survival
like I'm worried about what would happen
if I loved something that much well and
then the fear of you know everything I
think was Jim Jefferies that said being
a parent is is just the ability to be on
suicide watch all the time you're just
watching this thing that's genius yeah
so it's Jim Jefferies but but and then
you learn from having being responsible
for another human being that your words
and your actions how they affect another
human being and Through the Mirror of
seeing how it's affecting this human
that is growing and thriving in your
life you kind of
you realize that when you go out into
the world the way you act and the things
you say and the things you do how people
are affected because I think that we
don't know and you also learn how what
humanity is at its core you know we're
not nice we just aren't we're not born
nice
um when you watch a baby sitting at a
table
um and and and there's something they
like over here and they want it and even
if that other person is doing it when
you're a baby you'll just go and you've
got to go no no no that's not yours
share that's mine you just want to take
your shit if somebody annoys you you
just want to hit no you can't hit you
can't hit but our instinct is to be
violent our instinct is to survival at
all costs yeah and our instinct is just
to take whatever we see in our periphery
that we want in the moment you know you
know immediate satisfaction and
everything else that we become is kind
of a learned trained kind of
I just I love what you're saying because
I was thinking about this the other day
it's like number one I think that just
back to the embarrassment thing I think
so much of why people can't change their
minds when they have new information is
because they already said something
before they had the information and then
they're embarrassed to have been wrong I
think so much of this stuff online of
like I believe I'm for this candidate
and then some they're like well I love
them even more now because they're
afraid to go like oh I was wrong like
but I you know I'm big on change when
you get new information you can change
your mind that's intelligent people
don't change people don't change
anything you know and I realize also
from being a parent that I look at my
children's lives and that you're the
same age as my children so I look at
your life is so different your world is
so different than the world that I grew
up in it doesn't even look the same you
don't operate the same you don't even
feed yourself the same as I did you know
what I mean there was nothing Halloween
candy so I'm not a good no but you know
you know what I'm saying like everything
your form of communication the way you
do business even the way I got into
television is not the same way you know
the when I got into it you showed up at
the comedy store and that was it you
know and if you were at The Comedy Store
you were gonna get seen if you had
anything you know everybody was given a
city the irony is I'm going to say
something which is I think the new
Darwinism is people who behave like that
so the people that are only
communicating over text only
communicating over email those are the
people are getting fucked now the people
that show up in person call and use the
phone and do it the quote old-fashioned
way are the ones that aren't going to
get taken down canceled blackmailed
whatever so yeah maybe
maybe you know there's I I'm open and
curious to the new ways of doing I can't
tell you you know I've been successful
as a comedian I can't tell you how much
time I spend in my office with people
who have a three in front of their age
at the most and I and I'm asking why is
this funny and I and and not that I know
it's funny or not that I think it's
funny but I'm looking at why does this
have 10 million clicks yeah I don't even
get it and they explain it to me and and
you you you know I'm open to finding new
ways of doing it if I may yes yeah sorry
if that thing was on a stage alone in
front of a thousand people would it get
laughs I think it's context is
everything if it's a little video that
I'm only just watching to kill time for
free I'm laughing but if this person did
this in front of a microphone and I paid
80 it's not but not everything needs to
be on stage of course I'm just saying
it's when Comics go like why is this
funny to everyone well because the bar
is very low you didn't pay for it and
that's not true the point is that you
know the Three Stooges most women don't
like the threesome I love The Three
Stooges okay but most women don't but
I've been sitting I've sat with I love
The Three Stooges and they go listen
this is three guys they're poking each
other's eyes they're hitting each other
it's slapstick yeah yeah I've talked to
people why is that funny and if those
three guys were on stage doing that
today would that get a laugh would that
draw why aren't there troops of people
that are slapping because you're not
knocking themselves out
um so what I'm saying is context is
everything it does I don't I don't give
anything any less
um gravitas yeah because it's on the
internet
comment how many people can stand with
just a microphone and make a thousand
people laugh for an hour and a half
I wasn't 204. something like that right
and so that's a very small amount of
people and I think sometimes our bar for
what's funny is so high because people
are paying to come by the same token
when vine was something which no longer
exists I don't I couldn't think in six
second spurts it takes me six seconds to
just even
like right but there's people like if
you look at the Logan Paul that's where
they came they were Vine Stars they're
able to Garner but that's not stand up I
just think that comedy and stand-up
comedy are just two different things I
don't compare them to each other because
it's just like you know but I but I am
um amazed and fascinated about how to
engage and whether that's in stand-up
comedy whether that's in podcasting you
know look what you're doing now when you
got into stand-up comedy this didn't
even exist no and here's what I worry a
little bit about because there's a
little bit of a mental health crisis
among Comedians and I think what used to
kind of Hold Us Together were the
conversations we would have in the
hallway with each other even if we you
know like don't have the same comedy or
whatever just being able to sort of
corroborate your experience with someone
that also has been in the same way it's
like it's like seeing someone that you
know you were um uh what is that at war
with what's that called you were in my
what's that called what's it when you
were thinking about the puppet who when
you're in a foxhole well yeah but like
yeah some maybe someone you were out of
war with it's like only someone that can
understand what you're going through
right and I have this I have this theory
that any comedian can uh meet if they've
never met before and say five ridiculous
words and all of a sudden be best
friends you can sort of be like what's
your name oh James from Kansas oh um uh
Chuckle Hut Penguins oh wait hold on uh
Marty Connor over at rooster tea
feathers I know you
like you just have to say and then you
know there is always some camaraderie
where people have shared experience and
we used to do it in private in the green
room and those things gave you relief
and now we've started monetizing those
conversations for public consumption but
people slip into your DMs and people do
that it's just that you can you can
reach further I mean I have found that
when glass is half empty with you with
that I I think it's half full I think
it's actually better now I agree on some
level because now we're like going hey
man I'm jealous of you or hey man I
thought you were you know we're working
out but I find when I go to comedy clubs
now at least The Comedy Store
um we I'll be having like a great
conversation with the comedian we're
like let's save it let's save it for a
podcast let's not do that you know and
it's sort of like oh wait we still
should also talk to each other not
monetized like even that we can reach do
you know Jeff die of course well are you
friendly with you yes yeah so Jeff dye
last uh I haven't talked to Jeff dye in
three years yeah I haven't seen him in
person he's fucking hilarious no he's
really funny he's hilarious um last
night at midnight I got a text from Jeff
dye and it says bro
are you a member at equinox out of
nowhere
and I wrote back at 3 40 this morning I
wrote back I was but not now
do you have a cat allergy
and I haven't spoke I haven't spoke to
him since
hey Jeff dye look who I'm here with hi
Jeff so
yeah so are you on drugs what's up I
shared your text with me
she he told me that you texted him in
the middle of night asking if he was a
member of Equinox so are you okay do you
need an intervention or need some money
maybe go on Prozac
that late at night and the person goes
uh I was talking about how the Equinox
just opened by my house
oh I see how I'm in jail there all the
time and I was like oh so I just I I
messaged him
but you didn't tell me that and I'm not
a member and she lied whoever she is but
as all women do but I didn't I haven't
spoken to you or seen you in three years
you wrote it was at 12 30 at night I
have it right yeah that's not late for
me yeah for Comics that's early okay but
I'm a grandfather but I love it so at 12
30 and I didn't answer you until 3 30 in
the morning but but uh but you said are
you in Equinox and I went no waiting for
you and I told you I have a cat allergy
waiting for and you never even said oh
the woman that is there says she sees
you all the time you just left it why
would you just leave it
uh I don't know I probably uh hold on he
was looking for an excuse to talk to you
it's very sweet actually yeah when I
heard your name when she said your name
I was all excited I was like oh I'll
bother him what Equinox what what city
is it in
oh well this one just opened in Studio
City but she said she saw you at a
different Equinox she used to see it at
a different Equinox where I don't know
the Hollywood one across from The Comedy
Store Santa Monica I used to go in the
one in Santa Monica but I haven't been
into that one in maybe four years I
haven't seen you in three years I
haven't spoken to you in any context in
two years so it's good to reconnect no
we were just context no no we were just
talking about how Comics we can say five
words together and they're they're
connected we cannot talk to each other
for years and just if I see you text me
like it's the first thing I'll pick up
and it'll be something totally random
and it's just like we've been hanging
out for three years like that no time
has passed I
have to reach out to Comics all the time
if you look at your text thread Whitney
I think like I saw a thing with like
Dave
oh I'm gonna text Whitney that's cool
she's in this thing and you didn't and
Whitney didn't answer right
I don't remember but that's that might
check out
okay I answered right you answered me
yeah and then you have different types
of OCD but and then I didn't answer him
because I was busy organizing things but
but you're always busy
okay Jeff died Jeff dye I'm looking at
my texts with him oh that's gonna be
humbling for you Whitney oh boy okay
okay no this is cute okay you know you
wrote Dave Grohl movie respect I didn't
answer to that
and then you sent me a photo of my book
how long are these episodes
I support the people I like you know I
bother them late at night all right well
we love you and we just wanted to kind
of publicly shame you it's like a
Halloween I'm here for all right love
you bye
um okay so I want to we're gonna put
this on the screen I want to talk really
quick just about this incredible
technology okay
um uh of how we can sort of bring
Proto Proto
so Holograms I got into Holograms
because I found this guy David Nussbaum
online and he has perfected he worked
for the company originally that brought
Tupac to Coachella amazing and then he
has perfected it and uh I can be
anywhere now in real time I could be
anywhere in real time see the audience
and uh perform I could pre-tape things
but I'm actually there in the room it's
so incredible and then you can actually
look he's got he's from the Tiger King
collection of the
of Cruise wear I was totally blown away
because you can be anywhere and actually
see the people that are looking at the
Proto so you can be a Coachella and get
roasted by comedians that are at their
house or in a hotel room or whatever
they're doing but we can see everything
you're doing so you're actually having a
real no latency it's like
three-dimensional real-time Zoom let's
play The Paris Hilton one this is
incredible I used to have to travel over
250 days of the year
so just having this technology is
literally Next Level
obsessed but so I'm really excited about
that so I they moved into my building
and now I'm I'm sitting on the board and
the world is uh is kind of taking off
for us something so fascinating to me is
about when things that are ostensibly
like limitations in someone's life or
something that is seen as an obstacle or
a maladaptive Behavior or a limitation
then is sort of transmogrified into like
the superpower so like don't you feel
like sort of your the OCD with germs you
know kind of led to this thing that I
showed you I had a like a vision board I
have nothing to do with that technology
except that now I'm but it makes so much
Cosmic sense but that's why I gravitated
toward it when because I live online I
am I have as Oprah you know coined the
phrase fomo the fear of missing out of
everything anything and whether it's
because I need references for uh you
know just being out there and having a
reference as a judge on AGT or as a
stand-up comic or whatever I'm doing I
also don't want I want to find all these
new ways of communicating and and and
and just engaging and this way I can
engage in more than one place if I was
set up to do this I could be here but
this could also be this conversation
could be live in a theater and we could
be looking out at an audience and take
questions and take questions right now
so you could do your if you had a
sponsor if one of your sponsors wanted a
sponsor they could wrap that incredible
and make it worthwhile and then you can
do you know your uh good for you podcast
live at three theaters at once and have
the audience participate and you have a
sponsor pay for that incredible so it
doesn't cost you anything to get there
and then you have live tickets and
they're not disappointed the audience
isn't disappointed because you can
really see them and you can go you you
right there in the second row with the
red shirt hurt do you have a question
right now for me or Whitney no and and
it is amazing I want to do even for the
lobby of my stand-up shows I want to be
able to go okay hey guys meet and greets
but also before the shows all the stuff
that comes over the announcement that
people are just so pavlovian like
trained and not listened to I will take
photos after the show there is a meet
and greet no need to film The set you
can't film The set here's why there's
merch after the show you know it's just
all the boring ass announcements so they
can walk by and like that's what you
were to the show okay I'll try to take
that personally but then sort of be able
to talk to them from like just backstage
or whatever
um so they always do that that before
there was Proto I used to love the
announcements the announcements were
always fun for me do you fuck with the
announcements
not usually so I always do like we we
have fun so we play theaters and and
things like that there's sometimes the
the local DJ will or the person from the
theater wants to go on and do that we
just have to do housekeeping you know
welcome to the Pacific Theater
no photos no nothing next week you know
sound of music is going to be here so
get your tickets now and they have the
big thing you know and that's it before
the show starts they're doing the thing
we want to thank our sponsors for
tonight the uh Glenn Glenn's Ford thank
you so much for your support you know
and and all that so they say they're
going to go out and do an announcement
and I always say well we have
announcements too about certain things
and photos and things like that and they
go we'll do it and I said well don't
worry I'll write it out for you and then
no but wait but but I do I write it so
we write it out and we the first three
lines and I hand it to them just as they
they put the lights out the guy's going
where is your announcement where's your
announcement I go I'll get them to you
I'll get them to you but will we go we
go write them in the back as the lights
are going down
I hand them the paper and the first two
lines make sense you know recording
Howie's show will be is you know is not
allowed the fire exits are at the back
and then it made it due to code 693 and
then it goes off into this and you just
have this guy on stage reading this shit
that means absolutely nothing I've
videotaped it a couple times but we were
always doing things and then and then
the other thing that we do is after the
show
the lights go up and I'll I'll leave my
mic on you know and and then I'll like I
have a fight with the promo as people
are leaving I'll go you said you were
gonna pay me what the fuck is this what
the fuck or you'll hear me I'll go into
the into the bathroom and go fuck I had
to piss I mean I'm pouring the water you
hear you hear the pissing you hear the
toilet flush and you just see people
like there's 20 30 people left in the
theater just listening to me pissed what
else have we done we were always doing
things with the with the audience the uh
um
or the opening acts the opening acts I
used to
kill is uh
it's quick oh I just haven't I had an
opening act ludinos who who would go out
before me and he he was wearing this
beige suit he was wearing a beige suit
so I went I had him go out you got a a
squirt gun and I had a squirt gun and I
said Lou as the lights went down I go
you know what I know you're supposed to
do 25 to 20 minutes and what happens is
just let me know what your last joke is
going to be and this is as the
announcements he's about to walk out in
30 seconds and I have a squirt gun and
I'm squirting his crotch he doesn't know
I'm standing stop yes stop so he goes
out to go ladies and gentlemen ludinos
and he walks out he's got a huge whip
like he just pissed himself and he has
no idea I used to kill him horribly
I did so many things do you know about
Liam Neeson's pissing himself problem
no it's like a job I bring it up all the
time which is like so mean but I'll send
you some pictures of it yeah there's
like lots of photos with him with fans
with just like giant pistons on his
pants like I think he probably just
drinks too much and whatever but or he
just doesn't give a shit I did the same
thing to ludinos I I had uh he was we
were on tour and and I've told his story
we were on tour and he uh I said you're
having a great time and he goes yeah you
know it's a little it's a little hard
because everybody's here to see you and
you know it's
I'm being honest with you it's a little
hard so I hired a guy to come backstage
and just say you know I'm a huge fan I
saw you on Joan I saw you on this he was
an actor and we told him to do this he
went around the corner he acted really
drunk he was acting he wasn't drunk but
he acted drunk and then he went around
the corner and he had a can of pea soup
from Kroger's and Kroger
one Kroger yeah and and uh he took the
Pea Soup and he came out and he felt
like he puked on Lou's shoes and Lou was
disgusted and he goes holy fuck I got
one fan that shows up and they puke on
me I was just saying this so and I paid
this guy I paid for a plane ticket and
the next night wherever we were the same
guy shows up and pukes on his shoes
again
and and he goes one fan follows me to
two fucking cities and pukes on my shoes
my shoes are ruined and everything and I
started laughing and then he realized it
was me he goes you fucked with me right
that was like that was a joke right he
goes you owe me my shoes are ruined you
owe me shoes I said okay I owe you shoes
the next day we go to that this was in
my book I talked about this but we went
to the mall and I bought him beautiful
size 10 leather dress shoes and he loved
them he goes thank you and I'm sorry I
got upset and that and he goes back to
the hotel and uh we stayed in the mall
and I bought the exact same shoes in
nine and a half nine eight and a half
and eight and every five days on the
tour I would get into his dressing room
and I would just switch out the shoes
and then you know at the like after
about two weeks I see him kind of
limping he goes go what's going on Lou
and he goes you're not gonna fucking
believe him he goes I'm in my 40s and I
I can't tell you I go tell me what do
you think he goes I'm in my 40s and my
fucking feet are growing I'm growing out
of these shoes I don't know how this is
happening and that so the road used to
be so much fun I don't do that so much
anymore did you ever um like The Comedy
Store in you know like 80s night it was
sort of this thing that I just I'm just
obsessed with like you're like what your
relationship was with it and did you
have a relationship at all with Mitzi
Mitzi yes I love Mitzi Mitzi loved me uh
Mike binder brought me to The Comedy
Store he had seen me at Yak Yaks in
Toronto I was out here on a business I
you know I come from retail I come from
business I wasn't a comedian carpet
carpets fascinating and other things too
I had these uh you know I I like that I
have that entrepreneurial spirit and I
was actually out here I bought this
um I had the rights to this Uncle
Sherman uh flasher doll and it was this
little stuffed uh
bald man and you it had a trench coat
and you open up his trench coat and his
dick and his balls would hang out it was
like a joke gift you know and I got the
rights to it for Canada and it was
manufactured here in California and then
what happened is I shipped like tens of
thousands of dollars worth of Uncle
Sherman dolls to Canada and they got
stopped at the border because they were
deemed pornographic you know all these
dick in balls and then I made a deal
with the company where they shipped all
the the dolls and then all the dicks and
balls separately and then we would uh
adhere them in Canada and then all the
dolls got through and then I had these
cases of dicks and balls at the border
that uh weren't getting through so I had
to come down here for meetings of how we
were gonna get all the the nuts and
dicks into the country so binder knew I
was here and he said while you're here
you know I can get you on he got me on
at the comedy store and then at the
comedy store that's where George uh
George Foster saw me he had a comedy
game show called make me laugh and gave
me a job on TV and I did that but Mitzi
just said you're so good you're so funny
and always gave me spots so it was Mitzi
when Joan Rivers was doing when she was
the the queen of late night before she
did her talk show and she was her and
David Brenner were filling in for Carson
my first opening spot was in Aspen for
David Renner okay so so but she was the
she was the queen she was getting bigger
ratings when she was on than Carson and
when you knew that Joan Rivers was
filling in you know that's when America
would you know light up and everybody
would turn on the TV because she didn't
know what she was going to say about
Elizabeth Taylor it was so edgy and so
funny and so witty and you know I was
born with a coat hanger in my ear right
I could never say it now no no that's an
abortion joke for the kids they don't
they wouldn't know that yeah because we
don't have it doesn't exist anymore yeah
but and people don't know medical
procedures they don't know it is done
with a coat hanger because a lot of the
kids today have wooden coat hangers so
how do you do that so that so the thing
no more wire hangers was about abortion
right and a lot of women and lock their
keys in their pussies
is that okay
is that is that Politically Incorrect
because who are you going to call AAA
like you can just have a coat hanger and
get the key out of your pussy yourself
or do you call a tow truck
so anyway camel tow truck camel tow
truck I love that
I love that I wish I would have said
that but you did but anyway the point
and we're inspiring yeah what was I what
was that Joan Rivers everyone would tune
in
oh so I called
um so she was living in New York and
then she would come out when she was
going to fill in for a week and do sets
at The Comedy Store she would hone her
monologues at The Comedy Store and one
week when after I had been told by Jim
McCauley who was the booker for The
Tonight Show
um that I would never get on The Tonight
Show Johnny doesn't like what I do and
it's not the right tone for him I said
one more shot I called Mitzi Joan is
coming out and working this week and
she's got sets all week at 9 30 and I
said it Thursday was that the opening
spot back then no but that's when she
went on the show started at seven okay
yeah at The Comedy Store she's going on
at 9 30. I said the spot right before
could you put me on at uh at you know 9
20. you know right before her because
there's a chance that she may see me and
Mitzi was so nice there was no question
she goes Howie I don't do anything yes
I'll make sure and he'll probably run
late so Joan will come in and she'll
definitely don't worry Howie she'll see
you and I went there and she saw me and
gave it to me the first time she saw me
she just said you know you're very funny
young man have you ever done The Tonight
Show and I said this is my birthday week
it was November and she said well
that's that's I'm doing Mitzi I can't do
Joe call Billy samuth and I called Billy
sammeth the next day who was her manager
remember Billy yeah
and documented where he quit well the
one that disappeared he disappeared and
he became uh Barista and she had to let
him go because he was just he's a
barista where at Starbucks that's where
he left still now no he passed but he
was a great colorful character half the
people that worked there seem like
zombies so
yes is that a reference to the fact that
he passed yeah yes a lot of people
passed a lot of my contemporaries this
in this past year have passed which is
uh heartbreaking
I was probably the last person to talk
to Gilbert God for I was talking to him
when his wife is calling 9-1-1
to put him in the ambulance when I'm the
last Comic to talk to him you know but
that was heartbreaking I left Gilbert
and Bob
and Louie and now it's just winding down
to nothing can I just tell you a joke
that a brilliant comedian named Dan
Mintz said about um
this is how we process grief okay like
when Saga died you know we were all like
yes he would want us to be fucking
making jokes you know but it was just
too much but I I the only thing I could
think about was when um you know sagets
as you know his sister had a horrible
disease called fluoriderma and it's a
disease that like eats your skin until
it just eats you alive it's just your
skin hardens it's just it's not nice not
nice and one time we were at the Bowery
Hotel
um in like the lobby eating and I was
like you know like we're just coming for
show I was like starving or like lasagna
he orders like whatever he orders and I
said silent G oh
because I
fuck I st it's my favorite quote that I
never get right because of my fucking
dyslexia so I heard he's talking I go to
take a bite out of my lasagna and he
goes hey don't need my sister oh my God
oh my God I'm just it's like it just I
always think of that and I know that
that's you know he'd want us to joke
he'd want he would joke he went through
a lot of pain in his life he really he
lost everybody you know and her friends
and you know but he was just and that is
what comedy is there isn't too soon and
that kind of brings us back to what we
started talking about and but what what
happened was like you know when when
comedians pass there's conversations
that we have with each other on the
phone to cope and then there's what we
have to tweet but um Dan men's brilliant
comedian because you know he did he died
the same week as meatloaf
that means no sorry sorry no Louis
Anderson died the same week as meatloaf
okay and Dan said
um meatloaf dive of kovid and Louis
Anderson died of meatloaf
I love that that's how
he'll ruined you
know are you leaving no trying to Candy
Corn you want no on the floor oh do you
want some ball um washer the manscaped
are they a sponsor for you no what are
you looking for that that's a sunscreen
I thought you know I thought you won't
touch anything
what this yeah
that's a hairspray that doesn't work
no you don't want that
what do you need no
it's not gonna work you saw me do this
coming in you need to take the Moroccan
oil what's that hold on because they're
all broken here
oh wait you know what actually uses
is that hairspray good
no it's not is it
no Rita has on root concealer shit
it would have come out brown and I was
hoping I was gonna do that see you can't
break a prankster huh
watch how your life changes oh my God
so I
at first I didn't think it was anything
but I mean it's like
to go anywhere
I'm just emotional go ahead
I know how much you love Mitzi and I um
was in her office the other night and uh
you might just be crying because of the
actual aerosol you just put on your head
[Laughter]
I was making fun of it
oh yeah I love you I love Jennifer Love
Hewitt
foreign
this is the most disgusting thing I've
ever done my eyelids are now stuck this
is the most it's like it's pulling them
up a little at least a little eye lift
but I know what now I know what a woman
in porn feels like after they yell cut
this is all sticky and
everything is just I needed a shower
go ahead go ahead let's bet let's get
sensitive I know I know how much Mitzi
uh mentioned I know how much you meant
to her I sent you the other night that
picture that was cool yeah that
Hollywood Reporter picture that she has
in her office oh my gosh and very few
people have been in her office
um since she passed and no one's touched
anything
um and I went to her storage unit and
there's a lot to sort of figure out but
I wanted to give you some things from
her office that I think you might like
so this was her original stationery oh
my God
from from Mitzi the late 70s that was
the stationary shoes I've gotten notes
I've got notes from Mitzi giving me
oh my gosh
Isn't that cool that's so you're giving
can I do I keep this yeah it's for you
these are people have to know if you're
not in comedy what Mitzi was the the
grand Madam of Comedy uh you know um a
lot of these Young Unknown Comics became
known Jimmy Walker and Freddie Prince
and Richard Pryor Richard Pryor Sam
Kennison yeah and everybody who's
anybody that anybody who's listening to
this or watching this right now knows so
Mitzi you know is responsible for all of
us I was there one night when they
brought this young girl from uh New York
to audition for Steven Spielberg and a
bunch of other directors and her name
was Whoopi and she got that night she
got the color purple that night they
said they're going to put her in the
movie and that that kind of made her so
that you saw these epic moments
happening so this means a lot to me
thank you uh real quick Whoopi Goldberg
what was you know all these Comics that
you think of these like badass ball
busters if Mitzi was around that it's
like this this is who the people that
are scared of nothing were scared of and
admired more than she was his tiny
little Powerhouse tiny little Powerhouse
that church she would have these big
bows like Minnie Mouse and you know it
was just like she used her femininity in
a male dominated environment this is my
favorite podcast ever thank you thank
you this is really this is you're
amazing you're a beautiful person inside
and out here if you want to put them in
here
no I'll do it I'll do it you don't have
to do that's really cool I'm not no
tongue-in-cheek this is really cool it's
I cannot wait I'm gonna put this and
there's more to come you know and uh but
I just thought it was so neat
um this is so cool I just um I'm such a
giant fan the podcast that we did
together is coming out soon too right
Tuesday great oh next week oh awesome
okay so that this will probably come out
right after that so that's a perfect way
to consume both of them in the order
that they were actually filmed so I like
that thank you I end these very
awkwardly don't ride elephants
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]